there's a photo actually that i really
love that i want to put up on the screen
of colin um he was doing the weekend
update which is everything yeah and they
do a great job oh my god it's an
institution it is it's great it's so fun
so i guess he threw up a picture of
himself in high school saying oh yeah
with the music cut with the can we throw
that up there we go oh my god
okay so would high school scar joe be
into high school college um i don't
think so
[Laughter]
firstly that my brother had that same
haircut uh throughout the night both of
my brothers and i just can't
there's no way i mean
when
who decided on that cut as a stylish
thing
what hairdresser was like i'll try this
i i just love that though like that is
so cute okay so when i watch update
religiously
i love how much michael che just gives
him crap upon
guff upon tease yeah about you
about me and like every it's actually at
times i'm i think to myself like you're
gonna
some of it goes so far that i'm like
are people gonna like you're gonna
receive hate mail like here it's so
violent um yeah it's pretty it's pretty
bad um yeah michael you roll the rascal
is he a rascal what's he like in real
life i don't know him at all you've
never met him before i met him once at
backstage at the show and said hello
he's gonna probably not want me to say
this but he's like the sweetest like
munchiest nicest guy really yes he is
yeah he like says everything that
everybody is thinking but nobody can say
that's what i love about it and i love
when they feed each other the lines that
they have to read cold that they wrote
for each other and i'm like we're going
to be receiving email it's just
unbelievable i know i hope everybody
knows what this is you guys know what
that is when they give each other the
christmas present that i then like flop
sweat over i watch it on my couch like
this
oh
just like oh no
and yet everyone is there for it i know
look at the way he got you
that i was literally in my bathroom and
i was like literally looking at this
picture of you guys and i was like
getting dressed and i was reading a
magazine and i came up on this picture
and i just thought yes
that is the way a man is supposed to
look at his woman
and look at you
i know i'm like i'm like fist pumping
i'm so excited well you're just like
yeah oh yay i'm having so much fun and
he's just like that's my girl
and it's like
man woman take the gender out of it if
you could only have
that knowledge and maybe a little
photographic evidence that that person
gets you and appreciates you yeah that's
a really important thing i think just
like feeling
seen by somebody else and you know that
it's just to be seen is is what it's all
about
[Music]
you